un delicado equilibrio desde el comienzo
de la invasión rusa en ucrania la otan
ha buscado ayudar a kiev al tiempo que
intentaba evitar una escalada pero a
medida que el conflicto se prolonga la
otan se vuelve menos tímida en su apoyo
a ucrania en la cumbre de madrid se
establecerán los objetivos de la alianza
para la próxima década y se promete
comenzar este cambio de madrid show
let's go ver el sommet world y
acordaremos un nuevo concepto
estratégico y concepto estratégico de
madrid que será el proyecto de la otan
en un mundo más peligroso e imprevisible
world we would grid
acordaremos un cambio fundamental hacia
los términos de la defensa con más
fuerzas disponibles con más defensa
avanzada con más preposición a miento y
equipamiento acordaremos un amplio
paquete de asistencia a ucrania
o podrá por supuesto fans la cumbre será
también una prueba de la unidad de la
otan la alianza sigue dividida sobre la
adhesión de suecia y finlandia un paso
al que se opone ankara que exige que los
dos países nórdicos dejen de apoyar a
los grupos militantes kurdos y levanten
sus prohibiciones de ventas a turquía
el presidente de eeuu joe biden y su
homólogo turco recep tayip erdogán se
verán las caras este miércoles dos
diplomáticos de la otan dijeron que
esperaban que washington intentará
terminar con el impasse se espera que la
otan 7a china por primera vez como una
preocupación en su proyecto de concepto
estratégico y otra primicia los líderes
de japón australia corea del sur y nueva
zelanda fueron llamados a participar en
la cumbre como invitados beijing se
niega hasta ahora a condenar la invasión
rusa de ucrania